and now from the book TV archives
William Pelphrey chronicles the lives of
General Motors founders Billy Durant and
Alfred Sloan General Motors was founded
on September 16 1908 it's about an hour
good afternoon my name is William
Pelphrey and my book is Billy Alfred and
General Motors story of two unique men
the legendary company and a remarkable
time in American history before we start
this afternoon I want to emphasize that
I'm especially honored to be talking
about my book here at the Renaissance
Center General Motors world headquarters
especially in light of the headlines
that everyone is reading across the
country today when I started this book
more than two years ago I had no idea
that the timing would be such that it is
before we begin I'd also like to thank a
few people who made this event possible
c-span and book TV of course but also
Bertha Pruitt at the Borders bookstore
here in the Renaissance Center Adrienne
Hickey Irene magic and the rest of the
team at amacom books Christine Durham
the facility manager here at the
Renaissance Center and finally ed
Schneider and John McDonald's of General
Motors corporate communications who
facilitated all of the audio and visual
setup his background I'd also like to
give a just a brief summary of my own
writing credentials I actually started
writing as a soldier I was an
infantryman with the rifle company and a
heavy mortar platoon in Vietnam when I
came back to the world I wrote the first
Vietnam novel published by a Combat
Infantryman a book called the big V
which was nominated for the National
Book Award and won me a National
Endowment for the Arts fellowship from
there I began writing about Vietnam and
South Asia for the New York Times The
Atlantic Monthly and the New Republic
from there somehow ended up in the
Foreign Service was press attache at the
embassies in Pakistan and Venezuela
and then did another Vietnam novel
called hamburger hill in conjunction
with the film was the same name but as
they say all roads do lead to Detroit
and I ended up joining General Motors in
1987 was soon writing speeches for Jack
Smith who became CEO in 1992 and for
John's mail became the chairman of the
board the same year I left General
Motors to return to my own writing
full-time just about four years ago when
Jack Smith retired and ever since then
I've been more or less consumed by this
latest book you can just ask my wife
Lilia who I'm proud to have with me
today was that background as preface
what I'd like to do today is offer a few
comments on how Billy Alford and General
Motors came to be why I wrote it and
then read an excerpt about the two main
characters incredible legacies and those
legacies are timely er than ever today
to set the stage for questions first why
I wrote the book and by the way when I
started doing the research three years
ago I had no idea again how timely it
would be today but I also had a full
head of fairly dark hair as my wife can
also attest to what really intrigued me
at first was the dearth of knowledge and
information about the two men at the
center of the story the two portraits on
the cover Billy Durant and Alfred Sloan
Billy Durant was the founder of General
Motors and he created it single-handed
against all odds and in defiance of the
NewYork finance community especially the
house of Morgan an unlikely your
character you could not dream up in
Hollywood son of an alcoholic Niro do
well father raised by a single mother
when single mothers were shunned and a
high school dropout by the time he was
21 he was the highest volume cigar
salesman in the state of Michigan before
he was 40 he was the world's biggest
manufacturer and seller of course drawn
wagon
and carriages never get content to rest
on his laurels always looking for the
next new thing he took over the
management of a struggling young car
company called Buick motor in the year
1904 Durant had absolutely no background
in automobiles knew nothing about how
they worked let alone how to build them
in volume but within three years Buick
was the number one selling car in
America from there he went on to create
his general motors only to lose control
of it not once but twice and when Alfred
Sloan enters the picture the drama only
intensifies Billy Durant actually hired
Alfred Sloan in 1916 when he bought a
company called Hyatt roller bearing that
Sloane had taken charge of 15 years
earlier Lilly hired Alfred because he
knew a good manager when he saw one and
he also happened to know that Sloan was
afraid that his largest customer a guy
named Henry Ford was about to take
Sloane's business in-house and leave
Sloan as a supplier high and dry with
excess production capacity that was
arguably the most prescient hiring
decision of the 20th century but Durant
ended up watching from the sidelines at
Sloan transformed Billy's baby into
America's industrial icon slim was
Durant's opposite in all respects
introverted precise methodical and
intellectual the two were like oil and
water they were immediately at odds with
each other over how Durant was managing
all the companies he brought into
General Motors Billy's frenetic style
and his failure to establish central
controls drove Sloane absolutely up the
wall in fact Sloane had actually
prepared his resignation from General
Motors and was ready to accept a job
offer from an investment bank when push
came to shove in a boardroom showdown in
1920 Billy was out the door and on the
street while Alfred tore up his
resignation and soon took command and
that's just the two minutes and absence
of their incredible story
it's one of the most amazing stories in
the history of business or for that
matter the human species a few years ago
they made a movie about Howard Hughes
the aviator and dwelt on Hughes
obsessive-compulsive tendencies well
compared to Billy Durant Howard Hughes
was tame and middle class and Ebenezer
Scrooge was a wild man compared to
Albert Sloane and yet their story has
remained unknown outside a small circle
of car nuts and historians while the
name Henry Ford has almost been
canonized in popular legend and by the
way Billy Durant actually came close to
buying Ford Motor Company on two
different occasions only to have the
deal scuttled by Henry himself both
times at the last minute it's all the
kinds of material that no screenwriter
could invent but again the story has
never been told in a single narrative
the original General Motors building on
Grand Boulevard here in Detroit is one
of the stateliest buildings I've ever
been in in fact in its day it was the
largest office building in the world and
it's now designated a National Historic
Landmark as with many landmarks there is
also a legend behind that building
General Motors no longer occupies the
site but if you go there today and you
bring a pair of binoculars you can still
see a letter D carved into the corners
of each corner of the roof above the
15th floor the building was originally
going to be named the Durant building in
honor of the company's founder the
stonemasons had already cut the letter
DS into the corners when Durant was
thrown out of the company he created
when the building was finished it was
called the General Motors building but
nobody got around to removing the DS The
Legend of course is that the letter DS
were Billy Durant's way of getting back
at the management team that threw him
out all of whom had been brought into
General Motors by Billy the point of the
story is that even though a lot of
people here in Detroit know about the
letter DS I always found that not many
people seem to know
much care about how and why Billy Durant
disappeared from the scene in fact there
is virtually no material on Durant in
the company's archives It was as if he
had come and gone without really having
done much when you would ask people
about Durant you would usually hear that
he was a wheeler dealer a gambler and a
poor manager but not much more even more
surprising when you had asked about
Alfred Sloan the man who succeeded
Durant and turned the company around it
wasn't that different a lot of people
could recite Sloan's to famous business
strategies decentralized operations with
coordinated control and a car for every
person purpose and a lot of people knew
he created the annual model change which
really changed the game for all
competitors but again if you looked in
the archives you would find hardly
anything about Sloane demand everything
was about the company General Motors
rather than Sloane which only added to
Sloane's legend and of course was just
the way he wanted it what I found when I
started researching what ended up being
this book mainly in Durance personal
papers and dozens of out of print
manuscripts and books written in the
1920s what I found was that Durant was
far more than a wheeler dealer and
Sloane was far less than an infallible
genius but the more research I did the
more obvious it was that you could never
tell the story of Billy and Alfred
without also telling the story of their
peers all of whom as it turned out was
were just the strong-willed and
fascinating in their own ways as Durant
and Sloane work and their destinies were
all tied at some point to interactions
that they had with Billy and Alfred men
like David Buick who actually invented
the process for bonding porcelain to
metal that made modern plumbing fixtures
possible and then went on to create
Buick motor only to lose control of it
within a year to Billy Durant and end up
dying a pauper
in dying a pauper in the charity ward of
Detroit's Harper Hospital and then like
Henry Leland the master of precision
manufacturing who took over a company
that had been started by Henry Ford
renamed it Cadillac and then sold to
Durant's General Motors only to have a
falling-out with Billy and then start
yet another company called Lincoln only
to watch it go bankrupt and be bought at
auction by his original nemesis and
report the list of characters kept
growing as did even more complex mix of
events and social change that shaped
each man and the automobile itself not
to mention General Motors the more I dug
the farther I got from one thread that
one thread that every writer needs to
tie it all together in a single
compelling narrative as I mentioned
before I started digging I had a lot
more here and it was a lot darker
I found dozens of books and articles
about all the characters most of them
were written by people who were there
between the 1920s and 30s and guess what
they were all dull as dirt none of them
captured the character and the passion
of these two amazing men so the
challenge and the conundrum was how to
bring it all together and do justice to
them all and then I picked up an
excellent book Laura Hillenbrand
Seabiscuit about the legendary racehorse
you might not think of a connection
between Seabiscuit and General Motors
and I didn't either until I further run
until I read the first chapter which
talked about Charles Howard the horse's
owner who happened to be the biggest
Buick dealer on the west coast in the
1930s that's why I found the string to
finally start pulling the story together
the story of how General Motors unlikely
founder and his successor took it from
obscurity to the world's largest
enterprise was much like the story of
Seabiscuit the unlikeliest of
thoroughbred horses
seabiscuit rose from nowhere to capture
America's imagination in his race
against war Admiral the undisputed
champion of the day
well General Motors did the same thing
against Ford Motor General Motors would
Seabiscuit Durant and flown were its oil
and water owner and trainer Ford Motor
was war Admiral and Henry Ford was it's
even more unpredictable owner and
trainer and by the way the race between
General Motors and Ford Motor did indeed
capture America's imagination in the 20s
there were stories every week in every
newspaper across the country about how
Sloan and Ford were going at it
neck-and-neck they were even profiled in
the New York Daily News the way boxers
are profiled in today's sports tabloids
so with that string the horse race the
story quickly took command and started
molding itself into what became the book
and what I found was a uniquely American
story victories and defeats stumbles and
comebacks triumphs and tragedies today
the story of the way Billy and Alfred
put General Motors together and made it
grow is as timely as it is dramatic with
GM and the entire US auto industry in
the midst of an unprecedented
restructuring we're still dealing with
the consequences of these - of what
these two giants wrought for the auto
industry and America now that's the
short version of how I came to write the
book before we move on to questions and
answers I'd like to just read one
passage from the end of the story the
human side of the story about what
happened to Billy Durant after he was
forced out of General Motors for the
last time in 1920
although it's sad and even tragic in our
eyes today keep in mind that Billy
Durant himself remained the eternal
optimist through it all always looking
for that next deal always confident that
he would pull it off Sloane's story is
quite the opposite of course and I'm
sure we'll get into that in more detail
in the question and answer session
while Alfred P Sloan jr. transformed
General Motors into the icon of
corporate efficiency and success
Billy Durant's new dreams and did hollow
in September 1938 he stood at the door
of his Ramirez State on the Jersey Shore
while all of its furnishings were
auctioned off and carried away still
pursuing new dreams and schemes that
range from mining to toothpaste razors
and beer he borrowed thirty thousand
dollars from CS Mott who was then the
wealthiest man in Flint Michigan thanks
to his original partnership with Billy
Durant and $20,000 from Alfred Sloan
neither loan was ever repaid in January
1940 Sloan finally reestablished
personal contact with Billy inviting him
to attend the Detroit celebration of
General Motors twenty five millionth
vehicle rolling off the assembly line
Billy sat at Sloan's table and Sloan led
him by the hand to the stage to
introduce him to the crowd of executives
and dealers it was Billy's last
appearance at the institution he had
created single-handedly and against all
odds when portions of Sloan's first
memoir Adventures of a white-collar man
were excerpted in The Saturday Evening
Post in September of that same year
Billy wrote Alfred a letter thanking him
for what he called the handsome
compliments in the article fittingly the
letter also included a reminder that
there was more to success than the
science of management this is Billy the
high school dropout writing to Alfred
Sloan the MIT Phi Beta Kappa I do wish
mr. Sloan that you had known me when we
were laying the foundation when speed
and action seemed necessary you are
absolutely right in your statement that
General Motors justified an entirely
different method of handling after the
units were enlisted and you with your
training and experience surrounded
yourself with competent reliable men of
sound judgment vision and devotion to
the cause which is enabled
to build the general motors of today a
truly great institution but to sum up
mr. Sloane the early history of General
Motors reminds me of the following story
from the Civil War general wheeler who
came up from the ranks met major
Bloomfield a West pointer at the
Chickamauga battlefield at Chattanooga
in speaking of the engagement general
wheeler said to major bloomfield right
up on that hill there is where a company
a company of infantry captured a troop
of Calvary cavalry major Bloomfield said
why general you know that couldn't be
infantry cannot catch capture Cavill
cavalry to which general wheeler replied
but you see this infantry captain did
not have the disadvantage of a West
Point education and he didn't know he
couldn't do it so he just went ahead and
did it anyway
that was Billy Durant Sloane replied to
the letter in exactly one week with a
letter typed on General Motors
stationery it focused on Sloan's own
reasons for writing his book and made no
direct reference to anything in Durance
letter that exchange of letters was the
last known direct contact between the
two former colleagues while Catherine
Durant remained lovingly at her
husband's side through all of his
triumphs and tragedies they had no
children of their own
after the crash of 1929 they had less
and less contact with Billy's daughter
Marjorie and son Cliff from Billy's
first marriage cliff who had gained fame
as a California playboy and race driver
with no steady job and a more than ample
girth died of a heart attack in 1937 ten
years before his father ironically
cliffs first ex-wife Adelaide Frost
Rickenbacker went to the legendary eres
Eddie Rickenbacker after divorcing cliff
quietly began sending Billy and
Katherine money to help with their
living expenses the money came from a
trust fund that Billy had set up for her
as a wedding gift when she married his
Niro do well son daughter Marjorie who
had gone through three divorces and
struggled to maintain the image and the
lifestyle of debutante drifted into
drugs after her father's fall from Wall
Street just five months after Billy
Durant's death in March 1947 Marjorie
was arrested for buying and selling
illegal narcotics the story was reported
in the New York Daily News on September
16 1947 39 years to the day after Billie
incorporated General Motors mercifully
Marjorie's story faded from the press
after that one headline along with her
father's legacy
not until not August 1958 during General
Motors 50th anniversary year did Billy
Durant receive formal public recognition
for the greatest and most improbable of
all Gamble's and cheat and achievements
the founding of what we had become the
world's largest industrial enterprise
rather than a plaque or a statue billy's
marker is an inconspicuous ten foot
square slab of granite big enough to use
for a stage rising just two feet off the
ground in a park in Flint Michigan the
one-time protégé an employee who had
taken over the leadership of Billy's
baby Alfred P Sloan jr. was still alive
retired and sitting on the General
Motors Board of Directors at the time
Sloan did not attend the ceremonial
inauguration of their grants platform
however the marble slab was laid by the
city of flint rather than General Motors
Durant's memorial sits in the center of
the Flint cultural center opposite the
entrance to the Alfred P Sloan museum
which was also built by the city of
flint rather than General Motors today
despite the high sounding name the Flint
Cultural Center is dominated by empty
parking lots and the weeds surrounding
them there are two flag poles atop the
Durant platform but on most days no
flags fly the aluminum poles are
scratched with graffiti and the grass is
packed with weeds most passers-by do not
seem to notice the platform itself they
are mainly schoolchildren on bus
excursions rather than curious pilgrims
eager to soak in Flint's culture in the
end Billy Durant life played out the way
the American Dream itself plays out in
today's media culture a life in three
acts perfectly scripted did for 15
minutes of fame
Alfred Sloane's life and contrast
remains shrouded beneath the veil of the
unrivaled success of both men's true
passion General Motors as Durant's name
disappeared from the business world
Sloan's General Motors continued to set
the standard and raise the benchmark for
the rest of the automobile industry and
indeed all business until his death in
1966 today the debate continues about
whether many large companies including
General Motors stuck with Sloan's
original organizational and management
paradigms too long in the face of
competition from beyond the United
States while the lessons learned will
the lessons learned from how Alfred
Sloan adapted his General Motors to a
changing environment especially in the
aftermath of the crisis of 1920 be
heeded by a different generation of
managers and executives will it ever be
possible for any large enterprise to
achieve the kind of turnaround that
Sloan accomplished and then continue to
grow for so many years while the answers
to such questions grow more complex as
the pace of change in reaction
accelerates the legacies and the lessons
of what Billy ender and Billy Durant and
Alfred
Sloane brought for the world grow all
the more relevant to all those who would
be players with that I'll be glad to
take questions
I'm told that because of the sound
system we have you should wait until a
microphone reaches you and stand up
before asking your question
in the front row great book mr. Pelfrey
one question I have this kind of dipped
in irony I noticed that in your book you
say that General Motors was a top seller
of vehicles in Japan prior to World War
two and there's the irony what happened
there that's absolutely true and another
story that Hollywood couldn't have
scripted General Motors dominated the
automobile market in Japan right up
until Pearl Harbor in fact General
Motors had a larger market share in
Japan that it did in the United States
throughout the 1930s then after World
War two you can in a sense trace the
roots of many of the challenges the US
industry has faced to a man named
Douglas MacArthur General of the army
MacArthur was put in charge of
reconstruction in Japan and one of his
first decisions and it was decision made
by him alone was that no US automobile
manufacturer would be allowed to reenter
the Japanese market hard to believe that
Japan should rebuild its economy by its
own bootstraps needless to say no one
envisions what that bootstrap economy
would become the Japanese in fact
studied Sloan's business strategies and
Henry Ford's pattern of mass production
and as we all know had the advantage of
what MacArthur had brought namely a
government that was nurturing the
industry and in fact developing the
industry strict almost exclusively for
export rather than the home market
you look at Europe after World War two
it was exactly the opposite situation
General Motors had been a strong
competitor in Europe as at Ford Motor
Company before the war but after the war
with Germany and such ruins General
Motors had decided that it would not
reenter European markets strictly for
business reasons they didn't see the
market coming back for many many years
if ever
but Alfred Sloan received a phone call
from MacArthur's counterpart in Europe
general Lucius clay was in charge of
reconstruction and clay almost literally
begged Sloane to bring General Motors
back into Europe for patriotic reasons
clay was afraid that if General Motors
did not establish a presence no other
industrial companies would and that if
General Motors did re-enter the German
market with its prestige and image it
would bring others behind so despite the
advice of his own management team which
said this is a bad business decision
Sloane did reenter Europe the Opel brand
is still a leader in Europe today again
the opposite of the situation in Japan
that's why I say the whole story it's
Hollywood couldn't have written it full
of twists and turns and colorful
characters like that
just don't go it's a great book by the
way well thank you there's a there's a
lion in here today I'm almost done
reading it but there's a line of here
where you know we're talking about the
second house Tara Billy Durant says the
day of the Tinker and dreamer was gone
the day of the manager has had dawn and
I was curious as to what you thought
would about the which style of
leadership works best in today's world
Durant sir Sloane's in that passage
Billy Durant in a sense it really was
the dawn of a new era of the auto
industry had been created by men who had
no business background at all they were
tinkerers and vendors and dreamers the
industry by 1920 had clearly grown
beyond that and Alfred Sloan the trend
the transformation that he created at
General Motors putting in his famous
business strategy of decentralized
operations with centralized control
really did mark the end of the day when
one man alone like Billy Durant could
pull off a deal or come up with a new
car brand
durant was the epitome of the intuitive
salesman visionary you would see an idea
get an idea see an opportunity and go
with it period
Sloane was the opposite of course he was
the organize the ultimate organization
man in Sloane's General Motors decisions
were made by committees rather than one
man up in Flint and the world would
never be the same that's the kind of
transition I was referring to there give
you one example of the difference
between the the pioneer one man alone
style of Durant and Sloane's concept of
corporate management in 1908
shortly after creating General Motors
with Buick as the cornerstone Billy
acquired a company called Oldsmobile
Oldsmobile had actually built the first
mass-produced car in America and had
dominated the market for about four
years but it had fallen on hard times
when Billy bought it they needed a new
car in fact one of the jokes at the time
was a billy paid a lot of money for a
bunch of billboards and a song
Oldsmobile was the first company to do
billboard advertising and there was a
song back then called my Muriel's mobile
this was actually the most popular song
in America but Billy knew that the
Oldsmobile team was demoralized they
were losing money they had just been
bought by a man who none of them knew so
what did Billy do Billy the salesman he
dropped in on the entire management team
in Lansing Michigan unannounced and said
boys don't worry we're going to come up
with a car and we're going to succeed
and then unbeknownst to anyone he raised
his hand and three colleagues entered
the room with the body of a Buick just
the body a Buick Ken he had arranged
secretly to have that body shipped to
Lansing the day before he showed the
body to the engineers and managers who
still didn't know what was going on and
then he said does anybody have a
crosscut saw
and people scurried they came it came up
with a crosscut saw and he said okay
here here's how we'll create a new
Oldsmobile and he asked one of his own
colleagues to proceed to cut the body of
the Buick into quarters not unlike
Solomon cutting the baby in half
extended each quarter of the body about
six inches so you had a longer wider
design he said that's your new
Oldsmobile they proceeded to build the
Oldsmobile from Buick parts the first
time that that had ever been done in the
industry and by 1980 the standard
practice throughout the industry
needless to say within days well
probably within minutes Billy had the
Oldsmobile team pumped the car came to
market in less than a year and indeed
was in less than a year olds mobile was
profitable again similar situation in
1926 under Alfred Sloan Alfred had
created the famous price ladder with
Chevrolet covering the bottom of the
market Cadillac the high-end one of the
car divisions that Durant had brought
into General Motors is called Oakland
Oakland was the weak sister of the five
brands Sloane and his team knew they
needed something directly above
Chevrolet between Chevrolet and
automobile and Oakland was not cutting
it
so rather than the Billy Durant approach
of one man coming up with the idea and
just going with it
they formed study committees studied
whether or not they should create a new
brand in the new car for about a year
finally decided to do it they came up
with a new engine and that was the key
of the most powerful 6-cylinder engine
and that end of the market but to build
the car without giving Durant any credit
they took a page from Billy Durant's
book they used Chevrolet parts to build
the Pontiac car was on the market in
record time and was an immediate hit a
same basic decision with an entirely
different way of arriving at it today I
would compare the two styles with the
two guys that created Google I mean
those are clearly Billy Durant
characters Sloane look I think the
the closest clone as it were would be
Bill Gates Bill Gates and Steve Jobs
arguably created the PC market but of
course they had their falling outs but
they had very different approaches to
business Steve Jobs remains much in the
village ran school when he comes up with
an idea he goes for it no matter what
the iPod being the latest example Bill
Gates has said many times that he is a a
student and an admirer of the Sloan
School of Management the trick of course
is to get both of those styles in one
company and even tougher in one leader
much easier said than done
which makes business today much the same
kind of horse race you had when I was
talking about Seabiscuit and more Emma
Villas you were going through your
research was there anything that really
surprised you that while I didn't know
that and play it all together and
putting in context is awesome but is
anything it was almost shocking to you
that really you didn't conceive was
going to occur there are many surprises
and the more surprises you get the more
you get bound by the research and you
create your own problem and how to put
it all together but the most surprising
thing to me was all of the business
contributions that Durant made as I said
in my remarks
most people who even know about him in
Detroit they picture him as a salesman
and a wheeler and dealer but in fact
he's responsible for many firsts not
only auto in the auto industry but
business in general I mentioned the idea
of shared components for different
products that started with Billy Durant
the assembly line actually started with
Billy Durant and his lieutenants guy
named Charles Nash up in Flint when they
were building horse-drawn carriages
Henry Ford gets a lot of credit for the
assembly line
he actually mechanized the assembly line
which is certainly a milestone in the
industry but Durant was building wagons
on the same kind of layout up in Flint
the difference was that the people moved
rather than the parts on the line just
one more unknown Durant Cocker
contribution was the idea of retail
finance the leader Rance
and his financial advisor is actually
the treasurer of the company another
cult colorful character named John
Rascal in 1919 created a company called
GMAC
which has certainly been making its own
headlines in the last few months before
GMAC if you wanted to buy an automobile
you either came into the showroom with
cash in the barrel or you got a bank
loan on your own and most banks would
not loan money for an automobile
Durant's idea was why don't we finance
the purchase of the vehicle and make it
easier for the customer it not only
revolutionized the way automobiles were
sold but all kinds of big-ticket items
especially household appliances again
that precedent was set by Billy Durant
and there are several other again a
fascinating story there's one story I
haven't told about Durant and it has
really made me think since the book has
been finished the first person to read
the advance galleys of the book before
it was published a man named David Cole
who is arguably the most respected auto
and analyst in the world while he was
reading and he called me several times
to give me feedback and then when he
finished we got together for lunch we
ended up talking about three hours about
Durant and Sloane and what's happening
at General Motors today but one of the
first things he said was you know I
looking at everything that Durant did
the way he would start companies by
companies absolutely be obsessed with
the idea of the deal and then failed to
manage them the way Sloane managed them
up I think that Billy Durant probably
had a Dede attention the doesn't
deficiency before anybody knew about it
and that really made me think if you if
you accept that even as a possibility
just think I mentioned the Howard Hughes
story
what Durant had to overcome in his own
mind to accomplish as much as he did
it's an incredible story an incredible
man and just think what Durant might
have done if an indeed he had a leading
and there were treatment for it back
then who knows it might have been a
story of triumph to triumph or other
than triumph to tragedy
again it's
a fascinating human story for me and
that's why I could not had to write the
book any more questions
I guess two questions one in your
research what slums seems to be very
much kind of mysterious type character I
mean what do you think at his core what
what drove him to to say achieve what he
did and I guess secondly if Sloane were
around today and he he saw GM today how
do you think he'd view the situation and
not necessarily remedies but what would
you think his assessment of the major
problems are
well the first question for Sloane
general motors clearly was his life he
was married had no children very
deliberately kept his own name out of
the headlines in fact he created the
General Motors public relations
department in 1920s so that he would not
have to deal with reporters and he
insisted from his PR department that his
name was never mentioned in the stories
it was always General Motors in his
second book my years with General Motors
it's a 472 page book there's less than
one page to devoted devoted to his own
life and he only talks about his mother
and father and is a brother a totally
private man the company truly was his
life there were all kinds of jokes about
how obsessed he was with the company he
was known inside General Motors as
silent Sloan when he spoke people
listened though there's only one
recorded instance of Sloan ever doing a
transaction not directly related to
General Motors he had no known hobbies
although I suspect he read a lot of
books his wife and several friends
convinced him that he needed something
for leisure in the late 1920s so he
decided to buy a yacht he paid a million
dollars for the boat he called it the
Rene and had a full-time crew of 43
people in the cost of $120,000 a year
but it's loan in this case maybe not
unlike Durant he got bored with the boat
very quickly he only took it on a few
cruises and he ended up selling it for a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars I suspect that the only loss
that Alfred Sloan ever took in his life
the second question how Sloane would
view events today one thing I learned in
the research of all of those characters
and how the world kept changing even in
the 20s and 30s you cannot judge a man
outside of the context of his times I
think it is safe to say that general
Sloane would be proud that General
Motors is still here not many people not
not many companies have survived that
long especially when you think about the
core business
I mean General Motors is basically been
building one product namely the
automobile for nearly a hundred years of
you didn't ask the question this way but
I'll go out on a limb and maybe get
myself in trouble with a few friends in
the media but I've been in trouble
before when I look at the situation
today at General Motors and the the way
it's been covered especially here in
Detroit in the last few months the
parallels to nineteen twenty in
particular are many but Sloan had the
advantage of arguably taking a much
worse situation than today
I mean General Motors was really on the
ropes excess capacity up the wazoo
indebted I mean the company had been
capitalized at a billion dollars all
through the issuance of stock there was
so much debt that nobody really knew how
much there was but Sloan had the
advantage of being able to move in and
operate in a business environment as
opposed to today's media culture and I
talked to several friends in the media
and they will even admit the the news
business has changed in many ways not
unlike the automobile business the
competition is incredible especially
with the cable news networks and local
television the pressure is always there
to have a story and I hate to say it but
in some cases that's almost close to
creating the story and the reporters
know that they're under the pressure to
do it and I truly think that in some
cases they don't feel good about it
like you just one recent example for the
benefit of the c-span audience
just a week ago a little more than a
week ago all of a sudden someone started
a rumor here in Detroit that General
Motors is going to be firing salary
people like it never has before some of
the speculation was even that they're
going to let go half of their salary
workforce before you know it this is the
only story on the news in Detroit
especially the television stations they
were talking about black Tuesday people
being told to bring their laptops bring
the key to their office General Motors
was reserving conference rooms in every
building of the company to let people
know that they were going to be out the
door and guess what Tuesday morning
rolls around a total of fewer than 500
people were let go now that's a lot of
people by a lot of standards but a lot
of companies IBM in particular has let
go a lot more people than that and you
haven't had that kind of frenzy in the
media and you just imagine what that
kind of reporting does to the people who
are affected I can't imagine having been
a salaried employee last week with all
of that speculation going on and it was
in the end nothing but speculation as
have been in my opinion a lot of stories
even in the national media you know I
wrote for the New York Times for a while
and my editor was a guy named Harrison
Salisbury a legend I guarantee you that
a lot of these stories would not have
been in the times of the Wall Street
Journal in his day which wasn't that
long ago it is speculation it is not
journalism that's all I'll say about the
news media I see what
what kind of reviews I could get now you
talked about oil and vinegar between the
two men and then you also talked about
other pioneers and their stories and the
conflicting stories you have a couple of
specific stories that would be fun to
hear would the guy that immediately
comes to mind is Henry Leland and again
I mean the Hollywood couldn't have
written it Henry Leland was a like
Sloane a child of like two random
stories that child of the Civil War
although he was older than Durant he was
too young to enlist in the Union Army
but his brother didn't his brother was
killed and in his own legend as he stole
that he never got over that and
considered himself a patriot above all
else throughout his life in fact he was
one of the highest most highly skilled
machinists of the day during the Civil
War and decided to shift jobs to machine
rifles for the Union Army rather than
the engines that he preferred but after
the Civil War II he started a machine
shop moved to Detroit and immediately
had a reputation as the most precise
machinist around olds were a guy named
ransom old started Oldsmobile when he
built his first car he immediately went
to Leyland to build the engines because
of Leland's reputation for precision and
quality
well Leyland not only built the engine
for that car which was an immediate hit
he went one step further and built
another engine on his own much more
powerful and efficient he presented the
engine to olds and the old said forget
it I'm not going to retool my plants and
change my car just because you got a
better engine we're doing fine thank you
of course in a few years olds was in the
tank he's a new car Leland said okay
with you buddy so he turned around and
went to the backers of another guy in
Detroit a guy named Henry Ford Ford had
already managed to alienate one group of
financial backers with his first company
which is called the Detroit automobile
company it failed
Henry's reputation was bad as a
businessman but yet he got another group
of backers who led by the mayor of
Detroit guy named Mayberry who happened
to be the wealthiest man in Detroit they
backed Ford on the premise that Ford
would come up with a car that could be
built in volume and make money Ford did
not think there was much urgency in
making money with a car he kept trying
to perfect it and perfect it and to the
point where the word got out that his
backers were getting very fed up Leyland
heard about it went to Ford's backers
and they were immediately impressed with
his engine and on the spot they said
you're in Henry's out Henry was out on
the street they gave him 900 bucks and
the rights to proceed with a racecar
that he was developing which is another
story but Leyland immediately renamed
the company of Cadillac motor in honor
of
Cadillac the founder of Detroit you
happen to be the 200th anniversary year
of Detroit's founding Leyland made
Cadillac of success on the basis of his
fanatical obsession with precision and
quality when Billy Durant created
General Motors he wanted Cadillac for
those reasons he went to Leyland three
times made him an offer each time
Leyland up the ante raised the price
and each time insisted on cash each time
Durant at least in his papers claims
that Leyland had given him no inkling
that he was going to up the price at the
last minute long story short
Durant finally did bring Cadillac into
General Motors in 1909 but part of the
deal was that Leyland would be allowed
to continue running Cadillac basically
as an independent company that was fine
with Billy because he was focused at the
time on more acquisitions Leyland went
on to gain the reputation as a hard
taskmaster to say the least very
difficult man to work for as was Henry
Ford and most of the other characters
Leyland using his patriotic mantle
announced to the world in 1917 that he
was resigning from General Motors for
patriotic reasons the United States
entered World War one in April of 1917
started to build Liberty engines these
were aircraft engines for the US Army
Cadillac told the press that Cadillac
Leyland told the press that he had to
resign from General Motors because Billy
Durant did not support the war effort
Durant did not want to divert production
to a wartime materiel the leader and
immediately sent a telegram to Leyland
saying prove to me that you resigned of
your own free will said four telegrams
Leyland never replied finally again
compare this to today's media culture
finally Durant went to the press
directly and showed the memorandum and
assigned resignation Durant had actually
fired
Leland's up because Leyland would simply
not follow Durant's orders and would not
proceed to integrate Cadillac with the
rest of the General Motors organization
the way Billy's right hand at the time
the Chairman Pierre DeVaughn wanted it
Leyland went on to build Liberty engines
on his own for the army but the war
ended that no within a year after that
Leyland turned around like all of these
guys created yet another car company
called it Lincoln in honor of his war
hero from the Civil War problem was the
first Lincoln was reviewed by the press
at the time as a clone of the last
year's Cadillac did not take off in the
market and again long story short
Lincoln Motor ended up going bankrupt
Henry Leland ended up and you just
picture this Leland the guy who tear for
sten reward out of his second company
Leland ended up going to Henry Ford
begging him to help him out Henry
basically said sorry Henry when the
company Lincoln Motor finally went
bankrupt it was sold at auction and
there was only one bidder for the assets
Henry Ford Ford actually did hire
Leyland as an employee but needless to
say it was a tense situation Leyland did
not stay long at the Lincoln Lincoln to
this day lives on under the Ford Motor
umbrella Leland died not in total
poverty but far less the man he was and
in obscurity in the 1930s again there
are so many stories like that and the
amazing thing is it's never been told
from the perspective of the human drama
of all these guys
that's what I wanted to do
the readers can judge how well we did
one more question
well it's not quite a question bill I
have to tell you that when I was at the
MIT Sloan School it was a requirement
for us to read my years with General
Motors and we were tested on it and it
was quite boring and I just wanted to
thank you and I hope the students in the
future at MIT get to read this instead
so thank you or maybe both I actually
saw writers shouldn't do this but the
mention of amazon.com because it's
almost like cars they discount I saw
Billy Alfred and General Motors is
actually being offered combined with
Myers with General Motors and you get an
even better deal if you buy both books
anymore one more question
well congratulations on your success and
what's next for Bill Palfrey what's next
for me I don't know I mean as I said it
was two years full time with the
research and the writing and I know I'll
write something else but I don't know
what at this point I've thought about
two things several people have tried to
get me pumped to do a history of my unit
in the Army 22nd Infantry which is one
of the most decorated but least
glorified units in the army going back
to the war of 1812 and the Vietnam and
most recently they were the unit to
capture the Saddam Hussein but I I don't
know at this point another story that
I'm closer to and I don't know how I
would do is a a dear friend of mine a
writer named Harry Harry Caudill wrote
the first book about Appalachian night
comes of the Cumberlands saw a lot of
action in world war two leg nearly shot
off that book single-handedly create
darkness of the problems in the coal
fields in Eastern Kentucky just where
I'm from
but ended Robert Kennedy and John
Kennedy visited a Harry and he led them
on tours he had 15 seconds of fame but
the media and the country lost interest
and what was happening in Eastern
Kentucky particularly the strip mining
at the time and he ended up with
Alzheimer's and took his own life I
don't know what I'm going to do now
well I certainly want to thank everybody
again for coming - thanks - xev and
wonderful Borders bookstore here in the
Renaissance Center right there and if
they say if you buy it I will sign it
thank you guys